today's guest video is from Amy
advantage space who has brought along
one of the greatest and also the tiniest
props that I have ever seen Amy saw
yours one of the benefits to being a
professional space history nerd if you
get to add some amazing artifacts to
your private collection my latest
addition is this tiny piece of Captain
foil from Apollo 11 this tiny piece of
foil went to the moon and came back
through the Earth's atmosphere to be put
onto this piece of paper so I can hang
it on my wall but if you look closely at
the piece you'll notice that it's sort
of silvery and it looks like it's been
scratched off and there's gold
underneath so what's going on with this
piece of foil what exactly was that
silvery stuff and the larger question is
why does the Apollo spacecraft look
white when it launches silver when it's
around the moon and a dirty old once
it's come back to earth well it's all
part of the thermal protection system
thermal protection was a huge
engineering challenge for the men and
women who designed and built the Apollo
spacecraft not only was the vehicle
going to be flying through the vacuum of
space where it would be exposed to raw
unfiltered from life and also in the
shadow behind the moon where there would
be no light hitting it at all it also
had to return through the Earth's
atmosphere at lunar re-entry speeds this
is an insanely fast re-entry through the
Earth's atmosphere in the case of Paolo
this reentry speed was twenty four
thousand six hundred and seventy seven
miles per hour
or thirty six thousand 194 feet per
second that translated to a heat during
reentry
of over 4,000 degrees Fahrenheit that
meant the Apollo spacecraft is going to
need a very specific thermal protection
system to not only get the spacecraft
through the Earth's atmosphere in one
piece but to protect the three
astronauts inside it the thermal
protection system actually involves a
number of different elements first with
some Zeus protective cover this is the
white covering that fits over the
command module that you see as being
white when the spacecraft is mated to
its launch vehicle on the launch pad
ready to go to the moon this protected
two spacecraft from the heat associated
with launching through the atmosphere
but it didn't last very long the boost
protective cover was separated from the
spacecraft when the launch escape tower
jettisoned 200 seconds
after launch once the big protective
cover was clear the spacecraft looked
silver steps because the entire Apollo
command module was covered with a
pressure-sensitive captain polyamide
tape this tape was made of coated
aluminum and oxidized silicon monoxide
the tape was applied to the entire
external structure of the command module
with the gold side down and the silver
side facing out that's why when you see
pictures of the Apollo spacecraft in
orbit around the moon it looks like it's
reflecting space in a mirror beautiful
now when it came time for the Apollo
spacecraft to re-enter the atmosphere
this captain Cape wasn't exactly enough
to protect it from the searing heat of
reentry and it wasn't designed to the
Apollo spacecraft like the mercury and
Gemini vehicles the forest was a blunt
body design it had a rounded bottom and
a conical after body designed to
minimize convective heating during
reentry the center of gravity in the
vehicle was also offset from the axis of
symmetry in order to generate a very
small amount of lift this method the
spacecraft had a little bit of
controllability during reentry
so the blunt underside of the spacecraft
was taking the brunt of the heat and
that was where the last piece of the
thermal protective system was housed
that of course is the ablative heat
shield the heat shield of a honeycomb
structure bonded to the stainless steel
body of the spacecraft and each little
honeycomb was individually filled with
an ablative material that was burn away
as it was heated thus protecting the
spacecraft from the worst of the heat of
rain tree but the heat shields and the
bow shock generated by that blunt body
reentry
couldn't entirely protect the outer
structure of the spacecraft as it went
through that fireball phase of reentry
the captain was burned away a little bit
revealing the golden underside of the
tape but how is it that I'm able to
actually own a piece of the Apollo 11
spacecraft well it turns out that
recovery crews and pretty much anybody
who could get within arm's reach of the
spacecraft and this doesn't just go for
Apollo 11 this applies to all the
vehicles that went to the moon they
would reach up and just take off a tiny
piece of that foil as a souvenir so even
if at first glance it looks like a tiny
insignificant dime sized portion of foil
it's actually amazing to think that that
little dime sized piece of foil
to protect the apollo 11 astronauts on
the way to the moon and their re-entry
back through the Earth's atmosphere go
subscribe trying these channels for all
sorts of videos about spaceflight I
would recommend starting with her one on
how the Saturn 5 got to the launch pad
next time we have a video about
linguistics and music all in one